El viernes 28 de junio de 2019 se anunció
que la Comisión Europea había alcanzado
un acuerdo con Mercosur para crear el mayor
Acuerdo de Libre Comercio de toda su historia.
Y amigos, la euforia al otro lado del Atlántico
no fue menor.
20 largos años ha costado alcanzar un acuerdo
que afecta a una población de casi 800 millones
de personas y a una cuarta parte del PIB mundial.
El acuerdo alcanzado pondrá en marcha un
tratado de libre comercio de los llamados
de “nueva generación”, esto es que se
ocupará tanto del comercio como de otras
muchas cuestiones que tienen que ver con las
regulaciones públicas.
Pero… ¿Cómo afectará este acuerdo a Latinoamérica?
¿Qué beneficios y qué riesgos plantea?
¿Cómo diantres se ha tardado tanto?
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, vamos a
contestar a estas preguntas, pero antes…
antes tenemos que saber qué es exactamente
Mercosur y qué papel ha jugado desde su fundación.
¿Ha sido Mercosur un éxito o un experimento
fallido?
(UN MERCADO COMÚN PARA AMÉRICA)
El historial latinoamericano de procesos de
integración regional es taan largo… como...
errático.
Hay que remontarse muy atrás en el tiempo,
ni más ni menos que hasta los años 50 para
encontrar los primeros intentos de unir económica
y comercialmente
a todos los países de América Latina.
Es decir para crear algo así como un mercado
común donde se pudiera comprar, vender, invertir
o moverse sin que las fronteras nacionales
supusieran ningún obstáculo.
[Ya os adelanto que 60 años más tarde…
se sigue teniendo el mismo debate y los mismos
objetivos… así que os podéis imaginar
que algo pues… no ha ido bien.]
(El caso es que entre otros organismos en
febrero de 1960 se firmó el Tratado de Montevideo
que creaba la “Asociación latinoamericana
de libre Comercio”. La apuesta más ambiciosa.
Estaba integrado por las 10 repúblicas sudamericanas
junto con México y tenía una misión muy
clara: eliminar todas los aranceles y la mayoría
de las trabas al comercio regional en un plazo
máximo de 10 años. Desafortunadamente, nunca
se alcanzó esa meta.)
Sin embargo, amigos, mientras en América
Latina el proceso de integración económica
avanzaba más lento que una tortuga con reuma;
[casi como esa canción de Ricky Martin que
decía eso de “un pasito pa'lante Maria,
un pasito pa'tras”],
el resto del mundo no se estuvo quieto.
Durante la década de los 70, 80 y los 90
el proyecto de integración europea continuó
creciendo,
A finales de los 80 se plantaron los cimientos
del futuro NAFTA, el acuerdo de libre comercio
entre Canadá, Estados Unidos y México.
Y durante esos mismos años, los países asiáticos…
se lanzaron a comerse el mercado mundial;
En general durante las décadas de los 70,
80 y 90 en todo el mundo se avanzó un montón
en esa idea de impulsar el comercio internacional,
[lo que más tarde hemos conocido como globalización.]
Incluso en 1986 dio arranque la Ronda Uruguay
que terminaría creando la Organización Mundial
del Comercio.
(Tal vez fue esa especie de frenesí internacional
junto a las crisis económicas latinoamericanas
lo que finalmente animó a los gobiernos de
Brasil, Argentina, Uruguay y Paraguay a firmar
el día 26 de marzo del año 1991 el Tratado
de Asunción, el tratado constitutivo del
Mercado Común del Sur, Mercosur.)
Claro que, un momento amigos, porque una cosa
son las intenciones y otra muy distinta los
resultados.
Casi 3, 3 décadas después, a pesar de su
nombre, el Mercado Común del Sur, Mercosur,
ni siquiera ha conseguido convertirse en un
mercado común.
Y ese no es ni el único ni el peor de sus
problemas.
Atentos.
(MERCOSUR, EL QUIERO Y NO QUIERO)
Hagamos un ejercicio, tomemos los datos, ¿que
nos encontramos? Pues que sobre la mesa Mercosur
es un espacio económico enorme.
Hablamos de una organización que afecta a
casi 13 millones de kilómetros cuadrados,
casi 300 millones de habitantes y más de
tres cuartas partes del PIB de toda América
del Sur. Casi 3 billones de dólares
Tal y como veis Mercosur lo tenía todo para
convertirse en uno de los grandes mercados
del planeta.
Sin embargo… amigos, con el paso del tiempo
si algo se ha demostrado han sido precisamente
sus limitaciones.
Y esto es algo que tiene mucho pero que mucho
que ver con el propio espíritu con el que
nacieron los movimientos de integración económica
en América Latina.
Me explico, desde que se pusieron sobre la
mesa se basaban en lo que se ha conocido como
“regionalismo cerrado”, es decir, eliminar
los aranceles al comercio dentro del bloque
pero mantener e incluso incrementar los aranceles
hacia el resto del mundo.
En el caso Mercosur eso se hizo mediante el
llamado Arancel Externo Común, un arancel
común para las importaciones que tienen su
origen fuera del Mercosur.
Con él, se pretendía favorecer  el comercio
intrarregional encareciendo con un arancel
alto del 15, 20 o el 30% las importaciones
de fuera del bloque.
(Claro que, eso, evidentemente, es algo que
tuvo consecuencias.
Sí, esta barrera puede que ayudase a algunos
productores locales, como por ejemplo a los
productores de trigo argentinos,
pero con carácter general todas estas restricciones
frenaron a la inversión internacional, hicieron
que comprar tecnología fuera muchísimo más
caro y también impidió que los países de
Mercosur se integraran en las cadenas de producción
internacionales.
Y, es que aunque muchos políticos no se enteren,
así es como funciona el mundo. Cada parte
de un producto se hace en un lugar diferente…
De esta forma, claro, si impides o castigas
con aranceles la llegada de los suministros
que necesitan los fabricantes pues… Te quedas
fuera.)
Pero ahí no termina todo. Al final claro…
Si defiendes el proteccionismo con el resto
del mundo cómo diantres no vas a terminar
haciéndolo con tus propios vecinos.
Y eso es en cierto modo es lo que pasado con
Mercosur.
Qué ha sido incapaz de crear un verdadero
mercado común porque al final ni los diferentes
gobiernos de Brasil ni los diferentes gobiernos
argentinos han creído nunca en el comercio
internacional como herramienta para crecer.
Eso ha provocado que a diferencia por ejemplo
de la Unión Europea, las aduanas entre los
propios países integrantes de Mercosur no
hayan desaparecido.
(“Argentina y Uruguay son miembros del Mercosur.
En teoría, las fronteras internas no deberían
existir en Mercosur. Sin embargo, en la práctica,
las aduanas, las inspecciones sanitarias y
otros documentos implican que los camiones
tardan (en cruzar la frontera) hasta 24 horas
", Oscar Terzaghi para The Economist.)
¿Queréis otro ejemplo? Pues...Os voy
a hacer una pregunta a ver si la acertais.
China es el país al que Argentina le aplica
más medidas anti-dumping para dificultar
las importaciones.
¿Sabriais decirme cual es el segundo país
de todo el planeta al que Argentina aplica
más medidas antidumping?
1,2,3…. Puede que os sorprenda pero la respuesta
es ni más ni menos que Brasil.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. Con socios
así quién quiere enemigos.
(Se suele simplificar mucho el debate, pero
lo cierto es que el comercio no solo depende
de los aranceles. Para nada.
De hecho en América Latina en general hay
pocos aranceles al comercio regional… pero,
amigos, las restricciones al comercio van
mucho más allá: derechos antidumping, el
exigir y no conceder automáticamente licencias
a la importación, intervenciones en el tipo
de cambio, reglas de origen, etcétera, etcétera.
A la hora de la verdad los gobiernos tienen
mucho margen de maniobra cuando no existe
un verdadero mercado común.)
Al final, entre unas cosas y otras, los líderes
políticos de Mercosur han conseguido que
esta sea una de áreas comerciales menos integradas
de todo el mundo.
( Argentina ha aplicado cuanta medida proteccionista
ha podido contra los demás miembros. Y el
Brasil tampoco ha puesto mucho de su parte”.
Roberto Caicedo)
De hecho, fijaos cómo han evolucionado en
los últimos años las exportaciones de Argentina
a Brasil.
Sin embargo, ahora amigos, todo esto parece
estar por fin cambiando. Y es justo ahí dónde
se enmarca el acuerdo con la Unión Europea.
(HACIA UN NUEVO MERCOSUR)
Mercosur nació herido. Vale, más allá de
los grandilocuentes discursos políticos,
lo cierto es que nunca se tuvo la esperanza
de conseguir un gran resultado.
Eso sí, cuidado a pesar de todo los primeros
años no fueron nada pero que nada malos.
El peso del comercio entre los países de
Mercosur se multiplicó por 3, pasó del 8%
de todo el comercio en 1991 al 25% en 1998.
Es decir, todo apuntaba a que a pesar de las
limitaciones las cosas podrían ir razonablemente
bien.
Sin embargo, amigos, a partir del año 2000
todo se complicó mucho.
Los nuevos líderes políticos latinoamericanos,
Ernesto Kirchner, Lula da Silva y Tabaré
Vázquez cambiaron la idea económica de Mercosur
para convertirlo fundamentalmente en un órgano
político. Incluso se creó un parlamento,
el parlamento de mercosur.
(Entonces, del regionalismo cerrado se pasó
a lo que los propios teóricos de izquierdas
han denominado el regionalismo post-hegemónico.
Lo que no está muy claro qué significa.
Fue precisamente en esta época cuando Argentina,
Brasil y Uruguay dieron la bienvenida a Mercosur
a la Venezuela de Hugo Chávez y también
comenzó el proceso de adhesión de Bolivia.
Aunque eso sí, en 2017 Venezuela fue suspendida
por tiempo indefinido.)
El caso es que, de esta forma cuando Mercosur
no había aún conseguido la integración
económica pues… se dio carpetazo a la economía,
de tal forma que una organización que se
llama Mercado del Sur pasó a ser casi de
todo excepto un mercado integrado.
Así es como del 25% de todo el comercio de
sus países miembros en 1998, el peso de Mercosur
volvió a caer hasta poco más del 13% en
2017. Para que os hagáis una idea esta cifra
en la Unión Europea asciende hasta el 64%.
5 veces más.
Pero ahora, amigos, ahora con la llegada al
poder de nuevos líderes como Bolsonaro o
Macri, este bloque parece estar cambiado de
rumbo.
El primer gran logro de esta nueva estrategia
ha sido precisamente el acuerdo con la Unión
Europea para firmar uno de los tratados de
libre comercio más grandes jamás alcanzados.
Hablamos de 32 países involucrados, casi
800 millones de personas y 19 billones de
dólares de PIB. Billones hispanos, claro.
Y amigos, las oportunidades que se abren son
inmensas… especialmente para los países
de Mercosur.
Atentos.
(UNA OPORTUNIDAD HISTÓRICA)
Aún no conocemos todos los detalles ni tampoco
la aplicación del acuerdo va a ser inmediata.
Pero lo que ya está sobre la mesa suena muy
pero que muy bien.
(La Unión Europea eliminará los aranceles
para el 92% de las exportaciones de Mercosur,
y otorgará, además, un acceso en condiciones
preferentes a otro 7,5%.
Es decir, menos del 1% de los productos que
Mercosur vende a la Unión Europea quedarán
fuera del acuerdo. Y evidentemente esto es
algo que impulsará un montón la competitividad
de las empresas sudamericanas.)
Y ojo, porque la Unión Europea es un coloso
comercial que devora productos de todo el
mundo.
(“La UE es un mercado inmenso con 500 millones
de habitantes que representa el 20% de la
economía mundial, es el primer inversor con
un stock que supera el 30% de las inversiones
globales e importa el 17% del total de las
compras mundiales de bienes y servicios”
Informe del Gobierno Argentino)
Cada año la Unión Europea compra al resto
del mundo más de 2 billones de dólares en
todo tipo de productos.
Pues bien, de toda esta cantidad poco más
del 2% procede del bloque sudamericano.
La Unión Europea importa cada año más de
Corea del Sur que de todos los países del
Mercosur juntos.
Sin embargo, ahora este acuerdo le da oportunidad
al Brasil, a la Argentina, a Uruguay y a Paraguay
de hacerse con una porción cada más y más
grande de toda esta inmensa tarta.
Pensad lo que supone por ejemplo para el campo,
que es el sector que más exporta a Europa.
Con este acuerdo el 99% de sus exportaciones
a la UE quedarán liberalizadas e incluso
más del 80% libres de cualquier arancel.
[Y no olvidéis que Europa importa cada año
más de 120.000 millones de dólares en productos
agroalimentarios.
Hablamos de un un negocio descomunal.]
(Por su parte, el 91% de las exportaciones
de la Unión Europea a Mercosur también quedarán
libres de aranceles… Lo que supondrá por
ejemplo que las empresas brasileñas, argentinas,
uruguayas y paraguayas podrán acceder a la
tecnología y a las máquinas alemanas con
mayor facilidad y mejores condiciones.)
Eso sí, el acuerdo no se aplicará completamente
hasta dentro de 15 años.
Hasta entonces lo que veremos será una aplicación
progresiva… con la idea precisamente de
dar tiempo a los países sudamericanos para
poner en marcha las reformas que necesitan
para competir.
Algo especialmente crítico en el caso de
Argentina.
Por eso el grueso de las exportaciones europeas
se liberalizarán completamente en un plazo
de 10 a 15 años.
Es decir, Mercosur se beneficiará de este
acuerdo mucho antes que las mayoría de las
empresas europeas.
[De hecho, una vez que el acuerdo entre en
vigor el 76% de las exportaciones de Mercosur
estarán libres de aranceles frente a sólo
el 13% de las exportaciones europeas.
Y no, no penséis que en Europa no hay voces
críticas por todo esto.
Lo incomprensible es que todavía hay políticos
argentinos que se quejan.
Increible.
(Eso sí, hay una cuestión importante en
la que conviene insistir: un acuerdo de libre
comercio es una oportunidad pero también
es un riesgo si los países deciden no competir.
Con libre comercio hay que competir. Ya no
valen excusas, porque además el acuerdo va
a establecer su propia forma de trabajar.
Es decir, mientras el acuerdo esté en vigor
los gobiernos no podrán boicotear el comercio
de las empresas extranjeras. O al menos estarán
mucho más limitados para hacerlos.)
Pero en la UE no termina todo. Ahora Mercosur
quiere hacer lo mismo con Corea, Singapur,
Canadá los países del EFTA e incluso con
Estados Unidos.
Y también por supuesto hacer lo que tendrían
que haber hecho en primer lugar mejorar también
la integración económica de sus propios
países miembros.
¿Veremos pronto un verdadero mercado común
sudamericano? Está Mercosur despegando por
fin?
El tiempo dirá pero ahora turno para ti,
¿Hacia dónde tiene que avanzar Mercosur?
Dejame tu respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta.
Si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.